[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the journalist
and broadcaster Jenny kleeman and the
political editor of the Daily Telegraph
Ben Reilly Smith They'll be with us from
now right up until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the Metro leads with the jailing of
Thomas Cashman for a minimum of 42 years
for the gun murder of nine-year-old
Olivia Pratt Corbell it's headline
gutless
this is the front of the mirror on that
story mum's bravery and the cowardice of
a killer
as the express puts it 42 years life for
Olivia's life
the eye leads with the strike by
passport office workers which looks
certain to hit many people's holiday
plans this summer
the sun carries comments from a
television presenter Phillip Schofield
about his brother Timothy who has been
found guilty of sexually abusing a child
the guardian carries an exclusive with
claims of sexual misconduct amongst
senior figures at the confederation of
British industry the CBI says it's
already investigating
the Ft reports that Financial
consultancy ey has been fined and banned
from audit work in Germany for two years
after its failings over the collapse of
payments company wirecard
while the star has an update from The
Duchess of York on the Queen's corgis
apparently they're no longer grieving
for hello Majesty
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by Jenny
cleeman and Ben Reilly Smith welcome to
you both let us start with the biggest
story in town this evening and that is
the uh us while President of the United
States of America Donald Trump back in
New York before attending court tomorrow
morning Jenny
yes he's treating this arraignment this
appearance in court the first former
president to face criminal charges he's
treating all of this as a kind of
campaign rally he made his travel plans
uh public
hoping that people would be thronging
outside Trump Tower when he arrived
today I think there were fewer people
than he was expecting today not that
that's ever going to dampen his uh
completely unassailable self-confidence
um tomorrow he's going to appear at uh
the district court in Manhattan the same
court uh as Harvey Weinstein and various
other people who I'm sure he would not
like to be linked to and he's going to
find out what the charges against him
are they haven't been specified yet
um it's going to be something to do with
document fraud related to the hush money
uh that he allegedly paid to Stormy
Daniels but his lawyers don't know what
those charges are yet he'll find out
tomorrow
um he's going to be fingerprinted
apparently not handcuffed perhaps not
have his DNA taken but he may have his
mug shot taken and that will be a good
thing for him because he is using this
as I said as a campaigning opportunity a
mug shot might be a a good photograph to
put on a poster to show how he is being
victimized how this is a Witch Hunt
um how the Democrats are so terrified of
him and his opponents in the Republican
Party are so terrified of him
um that there is this conspiracy to try
and lock him up rather than run for
president again as we know he plans to
do uh in the 2024 presidential campaign
so the circus is only just beginning and
it's going to carry on tomorrow and Ben
do you agree that he he might be wanting
to use this as a campaigning opportunity
although we know that his lawyers have
um filed a request not to have any media
cameras in court
I mean they're clearly already trying to
do that I mean I actually was based that
in Washington for three years covering
Trump with the 2020 election he has this
unbelievable ability as a politician to
take bad news and do a kind of jujitsu
move on it and turn it to his political
Advantage so you've seen that in the
last couple of days the way his campaign
to find out these fundraising emails
trying to get as much cash as possible
um I think so much depends what that
image is going to be tomorrow
is it going to be a mugshot is it going
to be him coming into court does he look
defined I mean I suppose the jury's
going to be out well literally on the
case but also in the court of public
opinion there is a whole swathe of uh
voters in the country who are obviously
very critical uh of Donald Trump the
critical bit for whether he can become
president again is the Republican Party
base two years on from leaving the White
House he still has an unbelievable grip
on that party
um and so he is clearly hoping to use
this moment
um to turn himself into a martyr really
and say look the state the status quo
The Establishment is coming after me
coming after us and that's why I need to
Champion our movement again in them at
the next election uh Jenny you touched
on on the issue of his popularity and
perhaps the the crowds outside Trump
Tower not being to the the size that he
might have thought that they would be um
do you think that this is affecting his
his pop regularity
I think the people who like Donald Trump
are going to love him all the more as he
strides defiantly into the courthouse
he's a very polarizing figure and uh I I
don't think that this is going to
alienate the people who already love him
um but it'll be interesting to see how
he reacts tomorrow he is used to
surrounding himself only by sycophants
he does not like to be challenged and
you know these are people who have built
up a very serious case against him
that's going to be presented to him in
court
um but he as Ben says he'll split it to
his advantage that's what he does he is
a master of political spectacle and he's
using this to present himself
um as a martyr and I can't I'm excited
to see if the mug shots get released
what he does with them because no doubt
he will turn them to his Advantage there
will be people wearing t-shirts uh with
those mock that mugshot on as soon as
those pictures are released yes sir we
wait to see what dirt shots we we will
get tomorrow let's move to the express
ban and this is a sad news of the
passing of the former Chancellor former
conservative Chancellor Nigel Lawson at
the age of 91.
yeah well this story has only just
broken late uh this evening a lot of
political Journal is scrambling together
on the front pages I mean he was a Titan
of conservative politics Margaret
Thatcher's Chancellor left from 83 to 89
and one big core part of his legacy that
actually Taps into what's happening
today in British politics is taxed as a
tax slasher so it's 1988 budget was
famous it got rid of the 60 top rate of
income tax drops down to 40
um and obviously tax is a issue in the
conservative party that is providing
opinion the tax burden is going to the
highest point it's ever been since the
years after the second world war Richie
soon act says he wants to bring down
taxes but only once he's got inflation
under control there's a whole wing of
the party uh with Liz truss Stills their
head really in Boris Johnson kind of
flirting with that group as well who are
saying no you've got to start cutting
tax now you saw a bit of a rebellion
um at the last budget I think the
awesome is going to be another crunch
point so it's interesting watching all
the names in the party seeing your names
coming out this evening and praising
you're all certain because it does have
that
um bite in the current political
atmosphere yes sir Jenny B former prime
minister Boris Johnson saying that Nigel
Lawson was a fearless and original flame
of free market conservatism and also the
present prime minister Rishi sunak
saying that he he hung a portrait of uh
Nigel Lawson up in his office when he
was Chancellor
yeah he was literally a pin-up Nigel
Lawson a pin-up uh for the conservative
party and conservative chancellors he he
provided the kind of intellectual heft
behind thatcherism he was a massive
figure in the 19 1980s
um and and uh you know he he was a huge
symbol of post-war Britain and economics
in in post-war Britain he championed
privatization he became a a big
proponent of brexit and he um he only
retired from the House of Lords in
December he's lived a really truly uh
remarkable life I met him when I was a
student and he was warm and approachable
and uh interested and engaged in in
young people even then uh you know he
had long since uh retired from Frontline
politics uh Ben uh but he had a very
turbulent time he resigned in 1989 after
some some very serious disagreements
with Margaret Thatcher he precipitated
her fall from power in many ways and
they had this uneasy relationship I was
having a look through um some of the
obituaries just we came on air and one
group of such a big grudgingly uh says
in her memoirs that in 1983 she says I
had by now come to share Nigel's high
opinion of himself so even though they
didn't get on uh she couldn't help um
but respect him uh even though he he
played a very large part in her downfall
yes many others had a very high opinion
of him also let us move on to the Metro
um and their front page the headline
gutless referring to Thomas Cashman um
on his uh sentencing today Ben
well there are some of those criminal
cases that just kind of cut through
British society and really resonate with
people I think and this is clearly one
of them probably because it involves the
death of someone so young Olivia was
nine but also today you saw the scene of
the sentencing of her killer he got 42
years but he wasn't present in court and
clearly that seems to have caused uh
distress and frustration I think a lot
of people across the country are
wondering well how can that be that a
killer who has taken such a young life
and has given life in prison then
doesn't have to be in court to hear that
sentence and actually one of the debates
that's coming out um there's a report in
our paper tomorrow Dominic rather
Justice secretary has talked about
punishing convicted criminals who don't
turn up for their sentencing and there's
pressure now on him to speed through uh
that reform so it sounds like that might
be an area of political debate coming
out of this um horrific tragedy that
might play out in the next couple of
days
yes it also meant Jenny that him not
being in court he didn't get to hear the
impact statements from from the family
which is is really important
not only did he not get to hear those
Victim Impact statements that are
incredibly important for the family he
forced the family to wait they were all
standing in court waiting for him to
deign to uh to make his appearance and
when it was clear that he wouldn't
Cheryl Corbell Olivia Pratt corbell's
mother gave a really moving moving
speech she was holding a Teddy made out
of an old pair of Olivia's pajamas and
this was supposed to be her moment to to
confront the man who murdered her child
and shot her in such a horrific way and
he he denied her even that and he he is
truly a monster and uh she paid tribute
to the witnesses the incredibly Brave
witnesses that came forward and allowed
for Thomas cashman's conviction but we
know that the two guns used in the
attack still haven't been seized they're
still out there so there's still room uh
for the community to come forward and
and and do more for Olivia prattville's
fam who have had to endure so much at
the hands of these people yes and
continue as they say um their own life
sentence uh Jenny and Ben for the moment
thank you we are going to take a break
coming up
the end of the road for e-scooters
parisians vote to ban them from the
streets stay with us for more
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me journalist
broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the
political editor of the Daily Telegraph
Ben Reilly Smith welcome back to both of
you let us have a look at the Metro and
uh teachers on strike that stage more
strikes after they've rejected the
latest government offer new dates
Thursday April the 27th and Tuesday May
the second Jenny
yes right into exam season there'll be a
lot of parents uh holding their breath
over all of this and and uh you know
keeping a few expletives in uh teachers
were offered a thousand pound one-off
payment and a 4.3 pay rise which unions
have have unanimous well almost
unanimously overwhelmingly rejected uh
uh of of union members teachers union
members uh rejected this offer part of
this is to do with the fact that
teachers in in Wales and Scotland have
been offered a much better deal I think
in Scotland they've been offered a a 14
pay Rise um and so it's far less
generous but this is a really serious
standoff the education secretary Julian
Keegan had said that if the teachers
refused this offer that one thousand
pound one of payment wouldn't be on the
table yet again
um but it's incredibly difficult I think
a lot of parents have a lot of sympathy
with the teachers they haven't had a pay
rise for a long time they've had to
struggle through some very difficult
years of covert but so have children
um as well and at a time when we are
trying to get School attendance back up
to what it was pre-covered I know
certainly at my children's School
they've had terrible rates rates of
attendance it's a very difficult message
to be giving to children that you need
to uh that they must come to school it's
important for their education but also
that the teachers are are going to
strike for for pay so it's a very
difficult scenario for for teachers and
for parents as well as children and Ben
let's move on to another strike and this
time the passport office which is going
to style me a lot of people's summer
holidays potentially
yeah absolutely I mean the I think the
education strikes are only two days when
you look at the passport strikes there's
five weeks I believe 1 800 workers and
in the eye tomorrow they're suggesting
months could be uh sorry the delays
could be up to three months so anyone
planning a holiday whose passport is at
risk of them expiring that is scary news
um and having known some people who've
gone through I mean it's the uncertainty
of when you send off your passport not
exactly knowing when it's going to come
back obviously things tend to be done
um over post rather than going in with
the passport and having it processed
that day I mean yeah terrible timing
um Easter holidays are imminent summer
holidays just around the corner and
again it kind of links to the covert
thing you know for two best part of two
years families in this country
had really difficult times and one thing
they couldn't really do is travel
overseas and now the borders back open
and the pandemic beginning to pass into
the distance there's gonna be a whole
nother frustration on top of the changes
of brexit on top of the lockdowns that
prevented travel uh that are coming for
families in the next couple of months
yes I'm beginning to regret not going in
for that uh in person appointment I have
a passport in transit as we speak let's
um finish off with the Ft uh Jenny
e-scooters to be banned in Paris why
well you know people in Paris they do
things in a in a very serious way as we
know and there was a poll uh for just
four percent of the Parisian population
voted the e-scooter manufacturers say
but they they voted uh to make rented
e-scooters illegal they're Fed Up of uh
these scooters littering the streets
blocking doorways uh the e-scooter
manufacturers say of course that Paris
is going backwards that this is the
future of travel for tourists and for uh
younger people but you know I have had
to push prams around roads around
Pavements that have been blocked because
someone's chucked her and e-scooter that
way so there has to be a better way of
managing all but you can imagine
parisians couldn't deal with such ugly
things on their streets so uh they're
gonna ban them